hi my name is Lima and this is
resurrecting any recommendations
platform so before we really get started
in what it means to resurrect a platform
or resurrect a recommend recommendations
platform specifically I kind of wanted
to talk high-level what to expect the
next 30 minutes or so so first off I'm
gonna focus on the end-to-end machine
learning platform what that means to
build an end-to-end platform that can
orchestrate deploying evaluating
training a model so this really isn't a
case study and it's not to say like case
tied like case studies as much as the
next person but I'm just not gonna
emphasize on the tech stack I'm happy to
talk about the tech stack afterwards
with anyone if you'd like but the reason
for not focusing on the specific
technologies or tools that we selected
to solve this problem was because my
tech stack is probably different than
your tech stack which is different than
the next person's tech stack and you
know some people can easily just jump to
AWS or some people are constrained to
their physical infrastructure so instead
of focusing on the tools and frameworks
that we utilized I'm just focusing on
the holistic view of how to solve an end
and machine learning platform so that's
point number one point number two I'm
also not gonna really talk about how we
utilize recommendations in our Comcast
video products the reason for that is we
kind of all know why we need and how we
use recommendations in our daily lives
whether it's you know we're looking at
what we should have for dinner in st.
Louis or what we should buy on our
favorite online retailer or what we
should watch on TV we know the need for
recommendations and we know where
they're pretty much utilized or how
they're utilized so this will be
probably the first and last screen
capture that you'll see of
recommendations that's produced by my
platform that surface to our Comcast
video subscribers so actually there's a
good story about this so shortly after I
started leading the recommendations team
about over a year ago I was like I
should figure out what I'm being
recommended because I watch a good
amount of TV I have Comcast at home
what's our platform doing so you know I
walk home I turn on the TV I see ok
because you watch one room and that's
legit that makes total sense nailed it
don't really need to do anything else
maybe at mo
I need to like add a like fancy ETL
platform and then you know pull in a be
testing and then we can call it a day
and then I can move on to the next
project that was definitely not the case
at all this was just like the okay this
is great but how are we actually doing
this and the technical debt once I was
going under the hood the technical debt
that we had built from the five years of
orchestrating this platform was
astonishing and which was the main
reason why we needed to resurrect this
platform and last point which is really
not a point more so that everything
seems better in threes and I couldn't
think of a different Third Point Wonder
Woman so I like Wonder Woman and because
I'm in the you know TV movie content
discovery business a lot of my examples
are Wonder Woman this will be the last
time that you see Wonder Woman for us
the presentation I will do it get stash
on her and push forward so again hello
my name is Stu Lima I'm an engineer at
Comcast I lead the recommendations team
I really like data and that's a really
simple sentence but the reason why I
like data so much is that the way you
can analyze data at a large scale and
then may have insights and make
decisions based on that data and that
same data can be used to feed your
machine learning or deep learning models
is really impactful so it's a kind of my
sweet spot all right so what does it
mean to resurrect a recommendations
platform let's start from beginning but
before I start from the beginning from
where the platform was a year ago before
we quote-unquote resurrected it I'll
explain why I have this picture of my
cat so for two reasons one this is a
serious talk and my cat looks so serious
in this picture with an extending shirt
on it's just like her face is spot on
it's like I am serious about xfinity and
second reason is so the red community
the recommendations platform I wasn't
close to it so working at Comcast for
about seven years and I just recently
switched to leading it last year but in
between my start and last year I was in
close proximity to it to kind of see
what they were doing and what I noticed
was every year every few months there
was some initiative to prove that
improve the platform and
I mean by that is I think we were
realizing and we being this was before I
joined the team we're realizing that we
weren't getting the values that we
should be getting from a recommendations
platform so there would be you know a
few months where we'd be like let's just
focus on the research you know and then
what that meant is we migrated from a
collaborative filtering model to a model
that utilizes deep learning and neural
networks and produces predictions but it
takes far longer to produce those
predictions because you know deep
learning typical typically entails using
GPUs and we didn't have GPS on the
physical infrastructure so then that
added a lot of technical debt so then we
went back to collaborative filtering and
then we're like okay well let's focus on
the engineering maybe we can make the
platform better if we focus on the
engineering well that didn't really give
us what we wanted so essentially last
year this time we were on our eighth
life and it was really time to resurrect
it or just give up we we didn't give up
obviously ok so real quick before I get
into the details of how the platform was
before we resurrected it or I kind of
want to mention since we're all software
engineers here and we all know what it
means to write code and deploy to
production and support it at a large
scale machine learning is a somewhat of
a different beast if you compare machine
learning to your standard software
development for some reason the best
practices are not applied which I don't
understand why it's a few hunches but
I'm not exactly sure and I'm a few
examples a lot of times with machine
learning what happens is someone's like
I want to solve a problem and here are a
bunch of researchers and here are a very
small number of engineers so the
research Reacher researchers spend a lot
of time building some model so let's
pretend the end result is a Python
script utilizing tensorflow
super complicated let's not even go to
chaos let's go deep in the tensorflow
why not because the engineering team can
support that I'm being sarcastic so we
have this Python script it's not
containerized we have no idea to deploy
it we just execute it and we know ok
here's the input that we need to feed it
and then here's the output and we need
to do something with that output but
it's so much more than that but it's
amazing how often like you kind of get
stuck with this black box and then it
kind of takes magic on the engineering
so
to make that black box into a value so
to summarize it to actually get value
from a business perspective there's so
much more to do than just the
algorithmic aspect it's super important
important the research is I'm not
understating the research side but I
think because I like all these
commercials I mean there's a commercial
where there's I think it's common or I'm
not sure what his name is he's literally
like AI is the future this is true but
engineering is a huge part of that so
anyway so building platforms to support
your algorithms is when you'll start to
see the benefits so start from the
beginning what were our pain points so
what I mean by pain points are where do
we see why why was our platform
struggling last year when we were trying
to resurrect it point number one
infrastructure so unfortunately it was
constrained to 200 terabytes however we
needed bytes worth of storage so that's
obviously a no-go the optimizations that
we had to do work were like kind of
broke my machine learning heart
essentially when we got to a point where
we went over 200 terabytes we had to
decide to train our models with less
usage data just to fit our
infrastructure needs so let's say in a
perfect world you have a model that
should be trained on like your last 13
months worth of usage because you want
to get seasonality you want to see what
they watched last Christmas
for this Christmas are pretending
Christmases now we had to cut that down
because our infrastructure didn't
support that so we were taking a hit on
the performance of our algorithms
because our infrastructures didn't our
infrastructure didn't meet our need
second point is a it was a physical
stack which isn't a bad thing I mean
most of us probably have deployed code
on physical physical servers there's
nothing wrong with that but I think for
machine learning it's really hard to
scale on a physical infrastructure and
that's kind of alluding to how we
resurrected it I think you probably know
where I'm going with this
and then second part is as our
subscriber base increase our cluster
size stayed exactly the same we didn't
have the resources to allocate more
resources so obviously this platform was
built five years ago so
five years ago our subscriber base on x1
was a lot different than what it is now
and we obviously saw that by the
increase of usage that we had to store
in our platform but unfortunately we
didn't scale to meet that requirement
and the last point that about to make
isn't necessarily related to the
infrastructure but moreso the software
that was running on the infrastructure
we were running a community edition of a
popular hadoop distribution and I don't
know how that sounds to most of you but
to me doing that in production is
insanely risky so if we had an issue and
Hadoop and like HDFS and yarns a complex
system so I'm not a Hadoop admin nobody
on the team was a Hadoop admin luckily
we had a good ops guy but at the same
time it's very risky to run community C
Edition for production platform that's
that complex so anytime we had a problem
who are we gonna call not the support
team was kind of stuck on us to fix it
and obviously that would happen when we
had to do updates to the you know the
Hadoop versioning or add parcels or do
rollback sweep it was a mess so that was
our first pain point infrastructure our
second pain point was a data pipeline or
lack thereof we didn't have a data
pipeline so essentially how we got the
data into our ecosystem and and from
like a top level perspective data is
probably the most important aspect of
machine learning platform I mean you
can't do anything without data so the
fact that we were disc op eing from one
Hadoop cluster to our Hadoop cluster and
often that this copy would fail for
networking issues or whatnot
there was no monitoring we had no idea
if it failed we just we kind of realized
like two weeks later oh shoot we didn't
get any usage and if we failed to
consume Dayna again there was no
monitoring so we wouldn't even notice it
on the so at the high level like your
model is trained on usage data and then
you evaluate it we weren't evaluating
and we were just continuously training
it and then we put those predictions
into production we weren't monitoring
our predictions we had no idea that our
predictions were becoming stale so it's
just no good it was weak sauce
altogether
alright so our third pain point was the
orchestration
machine learning and that kind of means
a lot for example if we made a change to
our algorithm let's say we made a change
to our collaborative filtering algorithm
we waited something differently how long
would it take to evaluate that that
would take weeks
like literally weeks to figuring out if
this was an okay change because we
didn't have an a/b testing platform in
place and the whole point of a model is
to be able to iterate evaluate deploy
reiterate etc go do this whole dance and
we couldn't really do that we couldn't
do that seamlessly and I have an example
so the Platt for the state of the
platform last year before we resurrected
it
it was very batch sequential so we would
have we would get this data disk copy
the raw training data or the raw data
and then we would you know transform it
to be our future data set and then we
would session eyes it and that
essentially that job took 18 hours and
because it was sequential because that
job took 18 hours the pipeline wasn't
doing anything else we were kind of just
stuck and if you were gonna tell me okay
you're training your model takes 18
hours I kind of understand that but for
a job that's transforming data to take
18 hours is it's quite insane
so anyway so that was a pain point and
then overall like I said earlier it was
hard to make changes and evaluate ie the
lack of an a/b testing platform all
right so in other words the best
practices for machine learning we're
missing this is super super high-level I
just broke them into five buckets that
I've kind of already spoken to already
in this talk so we start with building
and training a model this is where
research and engineering get together
and figure out and data science figure
out what's the problem we want to solve
and then what's what what type of model
do we want to use for this do we want to
go the deep learning about where we
utilize net neural networks or do we
want to go something that's super simple
and utilize spark ml live for like first
clustering and then based on those
clusters we feed it into another
recommendation cell there's many ways to
go in the model side and then after you
have that you want to evaluate it an
evaluation is kind of done on the
offline sense meaning before it gets to
customers you have these base metrics
that you compare every change that
you've made to a model or you compare
other models to each other with these
base set of metrics it's like kind of
your baseline and it's typically recall
or precision or you can get fancier and
then once that meets like check that
sounds
good you deployed for either a/b testing
and you do online evaluations or you
skip that and go straight to production
the key box at the end monitoring it
actually should point at each part each
silos here because you should really
monitor the whole thing and to end but
really you should monitor it when it's
in production if you've got predictions
that are being served to customers in
production and if at some point that
gets stale and you don't notice it
that's not good
or if at some point you're let's say you
have a model that's supposed to be
trained daily and you just aren't
monitoring that the data that's being
fed to your model is actually fresh and
not stale then why are you retraining
your model so monitoring is a super key
aspect to follow this so anyways this is
the kind of the perfect world in a very
simplistic view and before I go into how
we approached tackling this I kind of
wanted to also mention that from my
experience the past year and hearing
others that utilize
machine learning at Comcast rarely is
the bottleneck on the machine learning
side it's usually on the engineering
side and again that goes to the reason
why when we talk about machine learning
the focus is always on the research and
it's rarely on how do we build a
resilient platform that can help
orchestrate that and it's the typical
problems that we have as software
engineers its infrastructure it's
building resilient data platforms that
can scale it's it's nothing new to our
lives but when you add machine learning
it makes it somewhat complex all right
so taking a step back what do we really
need to do to support the life cycle of
a machine learning model in other words
what do we need to do to resurrect this
recommendations platform so the real
meat of this discussion all right so
this is a lot of boxes and words and
again because I didn't want to make this
a case study and I'm happy to discuss
what technology stack and tools we use
to facilitate this so I took out what
the frameworks were using except it
looks like I left spark there so ignore
that we use spark but for the most part
this is like the life cycle of what I
just discussed you have your data
platform you need to sometimes like
transform that data to create future
sets or some time
the data is already stored in the way
that your model wants to use it for your
training and then you evaluate and then
you deploy this is super simplistic view
to dumb this down let's break it up into
four key components
there's your infrastructure which I
spoke to earlier there's your data
platform
there's your workflow management which
is super critical I actually didn't
realize how critical this was until
after we started getting into the meat
of running more than one model in
production at a time and then you're
monitoring and performance metrics which
is also super important so we're gonna
go into details on all of those next all
right
infrastructure so I kind of alluded to
this earlier when I mentioned physical
stack obviously I was going to my we
were Mike we've decided to migrate to
the cloud and look not only did like I
should it shouldn't say for us cloud
computing opened doors for machine
learning not just us the computation
power with GPUs and the ease of kicking
standing up instances and production is
it accelerated our growth in our speed
to resurrecting this platform when we
start for example so I keep mentioning
these two models that we have we have
this this core collaborative filtering
model and then we have this deep
learning model and honestly we there's
no way we would have been able to
experiment with this deep learning model
on this physical infrastructure so
migrating up to AWS was super key to
that obviously because of GPUs and then
easily is scale in and out elasticity
these are all kid learning these are all
reasons that most people migrate to a
tow us but they're extremely beneficial
from the machine learning aspect so a
few more points about infrastructure
since we moved to the cloud it brought
new problems better problems but new
problems we have to be really cognizant
of pricing there's a story a quick story
we have where when we first migrated so
it wasn't a lift and shift for us it was
like lift and shift meaning we didn't
take our MapReduce jobs and then just
run them in AWS we actually
reimplemented our whole platform and
that took a long time well we read not
reimplemented we redesigned our platform
and one of the things we were doing was
the first step was to build our data
pipeline so we had a
resilient event-driven Data Platform
that was just beautiful and amazing and
we could all get tattoos of the
architecture on our arms that's how
amazing it was
so the first step we did was we looked
into the main like framework that we
wanted use to consume the data so
typically the way it is is you either
you consume data from a cough
karyokinesis
and obviously other options for us is
copy or Kinesis and we are exploring
going the cockpit connector out for
Kafka and then the lambda route for
Kinesis because lambda because AWS
managed services worked really well
together however so when we were
experimenting with lambda there's one
day where we kicked off the lambda
function we had debug logging on
we had cloud watch obviously on and it
resulted in I think over twenty thousand
and three hours from logs which again is
a problem it's a nice problem to have
because that means it's not a nice
problem to have from a finance
perspective it's not nice at all but
it's nice that we can just spin off
lambda functions and consume data so you
have to be wary of that when you move to
the cloud and then the last point which
doesn't kind of make sense so I have to
really talk to it is it's really easy to
spin up instances what I mean by that is
it's really easy to just pick a
technology stack and deploy whereas in
your physical infrastructure you're kind
of constraint to the resources you have
so what we were finding was a certain
point team kept growing as we kept
improving the platform so it went from
three people to ten people and at some
points really hard to like keep an eye
on like the bigger picture and there
were folks that were you know spinning
up lambda functions and then you know
Redis clusters and what we went down the
dynamodb route and then someone wants to
stand up a Cassandra cluster and we were
just picking too many technologies
because it was it's easy to do in AWS so
then you start getting a lot of
technical debt of like is this really
all make sense how are we really
deploying this terraform I really came
to play later rather than sooner I wish
I came in sooner for us anyway so just
be cognizant of because you have the
luxury of luxury of being able to spin
up anything in AWS does mean you should
alright so that was infrastructure how
we solved that was moving to the
now let's focus on our data pipeline so
like I mentioned cloud infrastructure
allows us to scale when data fluctuates
this is something that we didn't have
before our goal was to build a
event-driven platform meaning it would
didn't really want it to be so batch by
that I mean in our previous platform we
would get this disk copy of data that
reflected the usage from the previous
day and then we would do something so
there was a quite there was a lag in
that I wanted to monitor our data
platform so that we would never again -
where we had stale data and then I
really wanted to focus on data stability
and quality and that means two things
that means the quality of the events
that are available that you're consuming
and then the stability so this goes a
long way for some reason the past year
it's been our part-time job to keep
moving from one Kafka topic to another
Kafka topic to another Kafka topic that
all of the same events but for some
reason we just have to keep following
the flow of data so it's really
important once you decide to go the
machine-learning route to make sure that
you have stability in the data and if
you don't then you're really it's
screwing me really difficult to solve
the problem at hand which is you know
producing predictions to do something
alright so another quick note on data
pipeline like I mentioned be careful and
the data that you decide to use as your
feature set its support for those
signals or that data set will be
deprecated you kind of are screwed so be
careful what you choose the way we
handled that is we decided to rely on
raw data as much as we could instead of
enriched data that was enriched by
upstream clients or downstream clients
and take on the enrichment on ourselves
and again that goes to the point that
the stability and the quality is super
critical okay so we went from this which
was our platform our data pipeline it's
not even a pipeline this is our data
pipeline last year so we got the data
disc CPD usage data which was in avro
format it was written to our HDFS
cluster and then we had a MapReduce job
that transformed it unfortunately and we
transformed it from beautiful Avro to
plain text and then that was written out
to HDFS and then we session eyes dit
this is the job that took 18 hours
probably because it was reading plain
text so this was the before and we don't
deal with this anymore
and this is the new it's really simple
we built like a pretty simple ETL system
right here that had a lot of code that
could be shared which is also the goal
so let's pretend we're starting from
scratch and we get we have a bunch of
usage data that we care for let's say we
care for what you watch and then what
you've searched for and then what you
voice these are all different topics or
streams available and confiden Kinesis
and then so for each one of those we
stand up these three lambda functions
and again there's a lot of code that's
being shared and a lot of a like
terraform and all that good stuff is
being shared in between these so it
doesn't seem as complex as it might look
so let's pretend that the use case is
for the data that you search for so the
search events come in through our
available in Kafka we set up the first
lambda function to get that raw event
and write that to our s3 bucket I also
lied them this is kind of a case study
I'm telling you what our text stack
looks like so we get the raw and then we
write that out to our s3 bucket the rule
of thumb is don't ever delete raw keep
raw because you might have a bug in your
transformation code or you might you
know for some reason your transformation
like T or your transformation limit
function fails you want to make sure you
have the raw so that you could reprocess
it and then once that file is written
out to s3 we have a subsequent limit
function that gets triggered that
converts from plain text which is for
some reason usually how we write data
into Kafka karyokinesis and then we
transform that into Avro because no job
should ever read plain text no data
processing framework plays well with
that and then the subsequent lambda
function essentially enriches it with
metadata because the first step usually
in all machine learning platforms is you
need usage did and you need your
metadata why not join the two so that
you don't have to add that complexity to
your model to do that and then we have
our little metadata stack which consumes
metadata from essentially a database or
a data service writes a snapshot to s3
and writes writes incremental updates
and the bootstrap version to dynamo so I
said
the platform that was it no I wouldn't
say an easy win to go from here to here
it took a long time it took a lot of
failures oh and then redshift actually
has been a huge component in our life so
we query redshift to extract training
datasets and validation datasets for our
models for shipped is is legit alright
so coming back to this view we talked
about our infrastructure we've talked
about our data pipeline now let's focus
on the workflow management and
monitoring and performance metrics
alright
workflow management workflow engines
help orchestrate complex complex systems
from a machine learning perspective
usually we don't want to train models
with less data but rather with more data
and we're seeing that especially with
our deep learning models the more data
the better the predictions will be and
as data grows we need to retrain those
models faster while consuming fewer
resources we also want to refresh models
more frequently to avoid stale
predictions and what I mean by that is
typically when you have a model you
don't just train at once and then
produce those predictions and don't
touch it again you train it at a certain
frequency Comcast we train our models
every day depending on where it's being
served to our customers on our video
platform Sony so that's a key aspect of
the model lifecycle so before musci
before before workflow management
machine learning and data pipelines were
run through a series of scripts or ad
hoc commands we all know what that means
so training and serving a model meant
mainly triggering and waiting for series
of jobs to complete for example job to
transfer the data transform the data
after that ran then load the data that
was a different job then training the
model then validate the model and then
deploy the models production those are
all a series of steps and this is where
workflow management comes into play so
there are tools that are designed to
schedule and automate machine learning
pipelines and data pipelines or any sort
of pipeline and they're super critical
to make your life easier there are
obviously open source tools available
list sophisticated interfaces depending
on the tool that you pick to allow for
managing -
it's all about DAGs and scheduling and
all that good stuff
examples are airflow Ozzy Azkaban and
Luigi we actually went through a lot of
experimentation with all them except for
Luigi so we started out with Uzis that
was okay that was obviously on our
physical infrastructure with the
well-known Hadoop distribution that we
were using and then we migrated off of
that we went to Azkaban this was before
we started resurrected so this was years
ago and then as of when we started
resurrect it we started utilizing air
flow I'm pretty happy with air flow so
far all right so let's work flow
management and you obviously can see the
importance for that next is monitoring
and performance metrics so for
developing each staring eyes the way the
ways to compare models it's different
than software development typically for
software development you have some
business cases you want to solve if you
write that code unit test it your QA
team tests it it meets those business
requirements and deploy when you have
models it kind of follows that but you
also need a baseline to compare when you
make changes so you have common metrics
like recall precision there's slew of
them but the whole point of having those
is that you can compare and then
evaluate if you don't have them then
what do you how do you really evaluate
the quality of your predictions so
monitor your models accuracy once it's
deployed into production that is also
using those common metrics so not only
are you deriving recom precision on an
offline sense when you're changing your
model but you're also doing it on the
online sense while it's running in
production with the goal being to
determine if your predictions are
becoming stale so if it become still
then you need to retrain it alright so
this graph is a snapshot from our recall
from one of the models that we were
evaluating back in back over the winter
in February or March or so and what I
like about this is that it shows that
data fluctuates on two parts it shows
that data fluctuates based on the time
of day and data fluctuates based on the
use case so the blue line is
recommendations for TV shows and if you
know anything about recommendations it's
a lot easier to recommend TV shows
because your TV show viewing habits
is kind of the same you will always
watch the next episode of this is us
because that's the show that you watch
but you won't always watch the same
movies so it's a very hard to predict
it's not it's harder to pick two movies
than it is to predict TV shows so which
is the red line of the movies which is
why the recall or the precision is
slightly lower what I like about this is
that this was taken during the Olympics
I think
and there's dip right there and that dip
orders yeah that dip kind of correlates
with viewing behavior because that means
data fluctuates people are everyone's
watching the Olympics no one's really
watching what we're suggesting them
because we're II unfortunately only use
nine months worth of your usage so we
had no idea that you liked the Olympics
so yeah so what this is supposed to
portray is a based on the time of day or
the seasonality your data will fluctuate
and you need metrics to evaluate those
changes and then even taking to account
your context like what you're serving
you need to have data that reflects that
movies versus TV shows for example all
right one last point about monitoring
and performance metrics you also need to
track the data quality of both the data
that's fed into your model and the data
that your model produces meaning you
don't want to feed your model stale data
or data that doesn't accurately reflect
what customers are doing in production
and then you also need to monitor and
evaluate the predictions that your that
your date that your platform is
producing your machine learning platform
is producing so both from historical
distribution of your data sets so you
can track the distribution of the data
you use to train a model three months
ago versus the data you use train your
model today like for example if you
train your model today and the data vert
is completely different than it was last
week there's an issue there and if you
feed that into your model you'll
obviously have issues and you'll think
it's your models fault but really it's
your data it's your data pipeline or the
source of where the data comes from so
monitoring everything when it comes to
data is super critical not only the
consumption of it but the quality of it
and how you're using it all right so
we're actually reaching the end
of this talk to sum it up four key
tenants needed to resurrect a
recommendations platform so that we
could support the life cycle of your
algorithms one is your infrastructure we
talked about how we migrated from the
physical stack to AWS to is our data
platform well you talked about how we
might created from that whatever that
was - Oh true ETL system 3 utilizing a
workflow management to orchestrate
everything end n not only your data
pipeline but also your machine learning
pipeline and a for monitoring and
performance metrics for all of the above
so yeah thank you
[Applause]